warum ist meine lieben freunde ich darf
euch heute möchten herzlich willkommen
heißt und endlich mal wieder zu einer
kreuzfahrt schelle
andrás tóth nie gemacht deswegen würde
ich sagen für auch direkt anderen lieben
freunde haben wie befindet sich hinter
der kamera habe die hat nämlich ein paar
sachen hier vorbereitet und zwar unter
anderem kopf -
wenn du mir ein richtig verpasst die
chance diese war aber die sache ist dass
wenn ich den kopf verpassen was das dann
hier durch gestrichen wird das heißt
dieses schild wird es dann nicht mehr
geben ich würde sagen
learning by doing
anzudrehen
wenn ich mit ihr geschehen
und dennoch allergisch gegen senf
ich bin dagegen sind
ich bin allergisch gegen senf das stimmt
doch oder
ich esse ich hab mir die nicht
allergisch salaten joker sie mussten
nicht essen hast du auch ein lauf habe
ich aber auch ich bin gespannt meine
lieben freunde was kommt bei mir beim
glücksrad paul ja aber nicht als aufgabe
ohrenkneifer
ich hasse die chöre du hast lang
französische video drehen
nur rad mal ich hab heute gutes make-up
ich mir verabredet noch nicht dass der
linken
[Musik]
sollte man dort gerne wir haben in story
karriere der sondermüll warum was macht
sandra ist es dann wenn die blue card
eine wette verloren und jetzt muss er
seine haare zur glatze schneiden und
lukas schuld mir noch eine million euro
und
nun kommt auch demnächst eine nase
operieren lassen falls sie fragt warum
er im januar fast weg ist und so dies
dass ananas und so viel spaß in sassari
streichen auch durch ich bin damit rede
und habe immer noch einen joker übrig
meine damen und was haben die ich bin
von game master hier gerade schott
betrieb mir natürlich überhaupt keinen
wodka oder so was wir haben hier
natürlich selbstverständlich vorher
wasser eigentlich schildesche das ist
doch kein ganzer schutz
junger wieder sich anstellt alter eine
flasche wodka auf ex trinken
in fleisch im club geht gesagt im
fleisch ich habe den schrott getrunken
obwohl meine oma auch weiß dass ich alle
nicht
alles reden die welt machen kann man
auch nicht reden
den handel mit 1 23
die haben entsprechende auf weg und
richtete dann mal mit ihm drehen einen
jogger ist immer noch vorhanden richtig
genau schauen was rauskommt wir haben
ist für mich eine kopflose
seine fein oder
[Musik]
nicht
das ist nicht alles drin guck mal hier
so viel drauf ist das
also schon mal was
braucht nicht aber nach milch
die nächste runde mein joker ist sex das
heißt egal was kommt ich muss das jetzt
machen meine lieben freunde
haareschneiden nimmt von einem höheren
abschneiden
das war nix haare schneiden kommt weg
freunde du bist dran sander ich bin
gespannt mit scheren und hessen spielt
man mit
einer
kopfnuss hat man schon die nächste
aufgabe zu stellen freunde wir haben für
sie haben wir männer hatten schon die
nächste aufgabe für zehn meine lieben
freunde
wir haben
langfristig zehn aden war schon die
nächste aufgabe zu zählen meine lieben
freunde kopfnuss hatten wir schon willst
du einfach immer in der gleichen
geschwindigkeit drin
meine lieben freundes anderer wird jetzt
einen tornado raus
mit einem 0,5
los geht's bereits ist bei
da dreht sich ja gar nicht
mehr gestiegen hier
geht
es
also
darum sprechen wir dann auf jeden fall
auch beck ich gesagt riemann und esteban
cenci sowie das papier fordert die
entweder nicht als meine lebensaufgabe
hat man schon oft
[Musik]
dort gewartet
auch boxen
verbrauch boxed nein nein nein ich
kann die nicht im bauch boxen oder
wollen wir waren darauf neben der box
arbeitet
was soll ich machen ja
warum habe ich mal was mit ihren füßen
die skizzen ist jetzt auf jeden fall
auch wenn das endlich realität wird
[Musik]
whatsapp anderer von wenigen prozent
schreiben
whatsapp schreiben motorrad vorlesen
irgendwie schwarz schreiben eine person
ihrer wahl oder ich hatte ein
komplettiert und hab mir nachts ein
drauf sorry war im schlaf und dort ist
ja einfach sagen das hast du jetzt ein
kumpel von mir geschrieben ja liebe
grüße und rui dadurch dass wir whats app
jetzt auch durch gestrichen haben haben
sie jetzt tatsächlich kein einziges
schild mehr hier frei ob sie ein drittes
rad team entsprechend haben wir alles
abgearbeitet meine lieben freunde also
wenn ihr einen zweiten teil von sandra
mit dem glücksrad wollt dann lasst einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier
abonnieren kanal und denkt auch die
glocke wenn ihr weitere videos nicht
verpassen wollt wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann schon mal wenn ihr auch
instagram vorbei das richtig sein dass
tori dann und
jungen sind dann
mario
hahn und seine neueste podcast bargau
aus wie super mario
der vor drei wochen oder
können sich leute trotz man nur noch
spotify
mit dem us wirtschaftssender setzt sich
hier vor
allem daumen hoch zeigen
[Musik]